First and foremost, uh.
I would like to thank the President of the Republic.
I know that the 49,
3 will fall on us,
than consequently,
our debates and amendments
participate in 1 vast comedy that is useless.
But I didn't think that the
President of the Republic would let us
at least talk for nothing.
Because when you know Emmanuel Macron,
we know that,
with him,
nothing,
it's already a lot.
So there you go,
thank you, Mr. President.
I don't know if you can hear me,
but I.
I am very grateful.
Uh. Especially me,
from the top of my 23 years,
have the honor to speak in the gallery of the Assembly
national for nothing,
have the right to criticize you,
Madam Minister,
it's 1 chance than all the others
young people have no others,
tried their hand at it,
they ended up on their knees,
hand on the head,
film,
as was the case lover the pretty,
or if they were young people
demonstrators against the pension reform,
young environmental activists,
or simply young people who wanted to
demonstrate against the massacre that is
currently in Gaza.
Do you take them
the 10 hours in police custody,
then uh.
You release them outside.
So, uh,
the Minister,
as it is a little complicated to criticize you,
I'll-I'll go instead, uh.
Go your way,
because,
effectively,
you don't do much for young people,
but.
But young people must understand that for you,
not much, it is,
it's already huge in fact.
Uh. Already because young people,
they don't vote for you,
eh.
In the last legislative elections,
they voted 40% for Mélenchon,
only 10% for your candidate.
So
uh. In the end,
they can only attack themselves.
But there is also an excellent study by researchers
Julia kg and Thomas piquetti
who explains that the vote
Macronist is the most bourgeois vote in history.
Never in the history of our country
the rich have not
so much the same for 1 candidate.
So you have understood everything,
Madam Minister,
these are the young people who vote for you.
So finally you do that your work,
uh. Parcoursup,
uh.
The refusal to raise wages,
no compensation for the rent increase,
meals at €1 uh not for everyone,
apprentices underpaid,
teachers replaced us,
but. But fortunately,
fortunately you
have abolished the wealth tax,
lowered taxes on companies that
allowed to tax billionaires,
fortunately you have removed the cve
because it brought in 9.000.000.000 anyway.
So uh.
We thank you.
So yes, ma'am,
young people must understand.
Uh.
You already give everything to those who have everything,
so it remains
not much for those who don't have much.
And uh. It's,
it's natural.
So uh.
There's still 1 other good news
as the youth budget will increase
from 3.000.000.000 to deux-mille-vingt-sept.
Uh.
Not to help young people stay up,
not to help them study,
to work or feed,
but 3.000.000.000 in the
very very in demand
universal national service.
Because, we must remember,
there is 1 investigation of radio France
which explains that in the
main concerns of youth,
you have in 4th grade the need for equality,
in 3rd the global warming,
in 2nd place purchasing power and in 1st place,
obviously,
the universal national service.
So thank you,
thank you
the minister to understand young people so well,
to create an institution in which young people can
regardless of their social origin,
to understand
the world and learn the values of their country.
In fact,
you justed school,
right?
We can say that you are 1 kind
of julférie of the twenty-first century.
Uh,
because we understood well that you had
abandoned the idea, uh,
equality and citizen training in schools.
And I want to reassure you,
when you were named
as head of the Ministry of National Education,
1 minister who has never been to public school,
the message got through very well on
what your ambitions are in the school.
So yes, finally, the.
Young people are ungrateful,
the small sports clubs too,
inflation,
strangulation,
communities pay for inflation too,
so they can't help them with subsidies.
And fortunately, there is Carrefour.
Uh Carrefour proposing,
if you buy healthy products,
to donate 1 small game to your sports club.
Choice. So,
Carrefour,
which increased its profits by 20%.
last semester,
who made billions
on food inflation,
proposes to donate some 1.000.000
to the sports club that you don't help.
Sometimes it tricks,
that makes it good,
It redistributes correctly,
uh,
as you like to say.
You had the bombing manual project,
deputy of France insoumise,
which proposed to tax superprofessionals.
You preferred the project of Alexander Bomb,
CEO and director of Carrefour,
who will then
keep the billions
and give some 1.000.000 to make some
advertising.
That's it. Uh.
Macronist policy as we like it.
So fortunately,
there is still the Olympic Games,
eh,
obviously.
Uh.
Where sports clubs can afford,
uh.
1 place at €700 to go
attend the track and field event,
€500 for the swimming event and of course
deux-mille-sept-cents euros
for the opening ceremony.
Thank you for your and for organizing this
so great popular festival.
So here it is, Madam Minister,
I tried a little to put myself in your shoes.
Maybe you do too,
you could try to put yourself in the shoes
of a young person struggling to finance his or her studies,
of a young underpaid,
of a young person looking for a job,
or even a high school girl who has no replaced teacher
2 weeks before 1 exam.
Uh, so there you go,
I will leave you because there,
I think born comes for 1,
49, 3.
So we will make as usual,
1 motion of no confidence
and the day. Where, uh.
We'll get you out of your departments,
we'll do what you do with it.
Uh.
Students, uh.
From the cross,
that is,
we will leave you 100 balls and 01/03.
To hear you well.
That's it.
Have a nice day,
Madam Minister.